uh pierre zakajewski who has been killed
in ukraine struck by incoming fire
outside the capital
kiev he's pictured here on the left with
press colleagues fox news ceo suzanne
scott
has released a statement saying it's
with great sadness and a heavy heart
that we share the news this morning
regarding our beloved cameraman pierre
zakajevsky pierre was killed in hirenka
outside of kiev ukraine
pierre was a war zone photographer who
covered nearly every international story
for fox news from iraq to afghanistan to
syria during his long tenure with us
she added his passion and talent as a
journalist were unmatched pierre was a
constant in all of our international
coverage i like countless others always
felt an extra sense of reassurance when
arriving on the scene and seeing him
with camera in hand fox news president
and executive executive editor jay
wallace said the legacy of his positive
spirit boundless energy and i for the
story will carry on
we extend our deepest condolences to
pierre's wife michelle and family
please keep them all in your prayers and
please continue to pray for benjamin
hall who remains hospitalized in ukraine
uh benjamin hall um a colleague of
pierre zakajewski caught up in that same
incoming fire outside of the capital